Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
Blake Mycoskie, the founder of
revolutionary shoe company Toms,
returns to the Tank.
This show's not about getting
the very best deal.
It's about getting
the best partner.
We live in a time
when people are questioning
the quality of the air
they breathe.
Everything you're surrounded by
is either sugary or caffeinated.
Oron: I don't think
you can do anything
without doing some good,
as well.
Sounds expensive.
Ooh.
If Daymond drops out,
bad things could happen.
I'm gonna match Kevin's offer.
Wait, wait, wait.
Who do you like more?
I love all you guys.
It's now or never, Michael.
No. No. You can't do that.
Why would you want one Shark
when you can have two?
Let's go!
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a healthier version
of a favorite snack.
♪♪
Hello. My name is Michael Pan,
and I'm from Portland, Oregon.
My company is...
Pan's.
And I'm here today
to talk to you about something
that's near and dear
to my heart.
Jerky!
Sharks, you're all busy
and know what it's like
to need fuel on the go,
and jerky is a convenient,
tasty, nutritious snack
people have enjoyed
for centuries.
Let's take a moment
to appreciate our jerky
in all of its glory.
♪♪
I can't think
of anything more satisfying
than ripping into
a meaty, chewy,
delicious piece of jerky!
Ooh! Almost brings
a tear to my eye.
Pan's is high in fiber
and vitamin D.
It's paleo, soy‐free,
gluten‐free,
and there are just
six simple ingredients
in our original recipe.
And all our flavors have
their own unique umami tastes.
Well, I didn't mean to go
on and on about our jerky
without you being able
to taste it.
I'd love for you each to take
a bite, so please go ahead.
Now, I can't wait
to hear your thoughts,
but before you share them,
I have to admit something.
That marvelously meaty texture
that you're experiencing ‐‐
That's great.
Really good.
Thank you.
Love it.
...is actually...
mushrooms!
Mm!
That's right!
Pan's Mushroom Jerky!
John: I was wondering
why it was so soft.
I love it even more!
This is great.
We have four delicious flavors.
Oh, my God.
Original, Zesty Thai,
Salt and Pepper,
and Applewood Barbecue.
All of them have
a delicious flavor
and satisfying texture
that fans of jerky love.
Now, Sharks,
I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange for 10% equity.
Who's ready to take
another bite?
Wow, that was a great reveal.
Thank you.
These are all shiitakes,
by the way.
So, tell us your story.
How did you get into
mushroom jerky?
So, my father was
born and raised
in a small fishing village
in Malaysia.
Luckily, I had the opportunity
to go visit family
to learn about my heritage
and where I came from.
And one of these
visits to Malaysia,
there was a bowl of food
on the table.
I reached in and try it,
and immediately, I thought,
"Oh, this is great.
It must be pork."
I was really confused.
The person who served it
was my cousin,
and he was vegetarian Buddhist,
and he had been making the snack
for himself, for his family,
for people in the area
and selling it locally.
And as vegetarians,
they had a really hard time
finding foods
that not only tasted great,
but also had
a really great texture.
And mushrooms are
very satisfying
and also very healthy.
I was blown away,
and I knew at that point
that we had something
that had to be shared
with the rest of the world.
What does it cost landed,
and what's the store selling at?
We make it for $1.67.
Okay.
Our MSP is between
$7.99 and $8.99.
Who's your biggest chain
right now selling it?
Whole Foods.
Whole Foods? Okay.
Yeah, we're in two regions
of Whole Foods at the moment.
What did you say
your sales were?
In 2018, we ended at $300,000
to start off with.
In 2019,
we more than doubled.
We got to about 755K,
and I'm happy to say
in 2020 so far,
we're at $620,000 in sales.
And how many stores
are you in now?
We're in over 700 stores
right now.
And where are most of your sales
coming from?
60% of our sales are on retail,
and 40% are online.
So, how much have you
invested yourself
and have you raised any money,
and if so, how much?
Yeah.
So, I put in $100,000 myself.
And how much did you raise
from outside?
None.
All bootstrapped.
What about borrowing
or anything?
I have borrowed,
and we have a few loans,
and, obviously,
with COVID happening,
we were one of the
businesses that took
advantage of the PPP loan.
I also took an SBA
COVID Disaster loan, as well.
Would you say you're on track
to do $1 million this year?
Yes, and we think
we're gonna get 1.5.
1.5?
We're about $95,000 to $100,000
in sales a month right now.
I want to talk about something
more exciting and fun ‐‐
Mycoskie: How good it tastes.
Yes.
Which is ‐‐
Which is these.
Incredible.
Thank you.
Look at this.
I have none left.
You're not the only one.
Seriously,
I'm in the bags here.
Yeah.
This is fantastic.
Thank you, Lori.
Totally my cup of tea.
Now, is there
anybody else doing this?
There are others
starting to do this,
and that's obviously
why I'm here.
We want to move faster.
But we really rely on,
our taste and texture
is superior to anyone else.
♪♪
Michael,
you making money yet?
We are.
Our margin's around 77%
across all channels
at the moment.
What will
the company make
if it hits its sales targets
this year?
In profit.
So far this year,
we are netting $61,000.
So you're saying
there's a 10% profit margin?
Yes.
John: So, I'm gonna
just sum this all up.
You're offering 10%
for $300,000.
You would have to grow
the company significantly
for me to make at least twice
my money back, right?
And I like this stuff,
but for me to get my money back
and a little something extra,
it's a long road.
So I'm out.
Thank you very much.
So, I want you to know,
I adore this.
I love jerky,
but I don't want to eat jerky.
I don't want
to eat high sodium.
This is so healthy.
It tastes fantastic ‐‐
all of them.
Blake and I
were talking.
Between the two of us,
we'd like to make you an offer.
And I want to share a little bit
of our thinking.
My Bantam Bagels, we got into
Starbucks nationwide,
and that was 9,000 stores.
Starbucks is great.
If you can get in there
and on their shelf,
they don't have a lot
of things to pick,
They don't.
and they like healthy stuff
like this.
Mycoskie: Starbucks is
gonna love this.
And we both have incredible
relationships there.
Yes.
And then
the Whole Foods,
Albertsons, Kroger,
even Wal‐Mart ‐‐
everybody wants
something like this.
So, our thought was
to try to blow this up
into all those places.
But Blake's gonna
tell you our ask,
because to do that,
we need to be special partners.
[ Laughs ] "Special partners."
Yeah, I mean,
here's the thing.
I only make two,
maybe three investments a year.
And the reason
I do that is,
I want to come in
and be a founder.
I want to be a partner.
I want to be, like,
really building something.
And I think this
has enormous potential.
Sounds expensive.
[ Chuckles ]
What I like about
where you are right now is,
it reminds me a lot
of where I was at Toms,
in that until I sold Toms,
I owned 100% of the business.
I brought in a 50% partner
seven years in...
Ohhhh!
...to help grow globally.
I smell 50%.
And, um...
Are you gonna
bring this offer?
It's not gonna be that strong.
Let's hear it.
That's a great way to tee it up,
though.
John: I think it's 40%.
I think it's 40.
I think it's 20‐20.
What Lori and I
want to do is,
we think the 300K,
we'd love to do that,
but we need to
see 30% for us ‐‐
15% for me
and 15% for Lori.
Michael ‐‐ Michael ‐‐
Now, before you interrupt,
let me just say is,
this show's not about, like,
getting the very best deal.
It's about getting
the best partner,
and a great partner is
gonna build your business...
Exactly.
far better
than 5 or 10 percent points
you might not have wanted
to give away.
So, we would love
to be your partner.
Greiner: But also,
we will blow it up.
But I'm gonna do what
Mark Cuban does all the time.
I'm gonna say
you have to tell us now.
Well, Michael ‐‐
Michael, here.
Just real quick.
I've done this before.
This would be added
to the portfolio.
I'll do 300K for 20%
if you say yes now.
No. No. You can't do that.
[ Mycoskie laughs ]
It's now or never,
Michael.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Michael has two offers
on the table ‐‐
one from Blake and Lori
and another from Mark
for his mushroom jerky company,
Pan's.
What Lori and I
want to do is,
we think the 300K,
we'd love to do that,
but we need to
see 30% for us ‐‐
15% for me
and 15% for Lori.
Cuban: Michael ‐‐
Michael, here.
Just real quick.
I've done this before.
This would be added
to the portfolio.
I'll do 300K for 20%
if you say yes now.
No. No. You can't do that.
[ Mycoskie laughs ]
Because Mark does that
all the time.
It's now or never, Michael.
So, Blake ‐‐ Blake...
Why would you want one Shark
when you can have two?
Don't do that.
What are you gonna do?
We are passionate
about this.
Passionate about it.
Michael, I do it ‐‐
I've done it all the time.
It's a decision how much equity
you want to part with.
Mycoskie: He used
the word "portfolio."
You're just gonna be one
of many people in his portfolio.
No, no,
the whole point is,
they're all
plant‐based companies,
so we already are
in Whole Foods.
We already have Alyssa's.
We already have Snacklins.
You're not in Starbucks.
And ‐‐
That's not true.
That is not true, 'cause
we just got Unreal Deli...
He usually doesn't
wait this long.
You better watch.
...another plant‐based,
we got them into Starbucks.
Well, all I can say ‐‐
One of many
or someone who's gonna focus?
And I'm a vegetarian,
so I live this.
You have to make a decision.
And I'm pretty much
a vegetarian.
What would you like to do,
Michael?
Wait, don't force him on...
I am!
This is a very big decision ‐‐
his whole business.
Don't force him.
Do you understand the offers?
That's right.
It's his life.
Do you understand
both offers?
It's a lot going on in my head
right now, but...
Well, let's just highlight it.
It's $300,000 for 30%
or it's $300,000 for 20%.
And two Sharks
that are going to ‐‐
Mycoskie:
But you get two Sharks or one.
And I'd say I'm more
than just one Shark
because I'm gonna be
more focused on this.
[ Laughs ] Yeah,
but the difference is,
I've done it multiple times.
We're really like three Sharks
'cause we're each
1 1/2 Sharks.
John: Be truthful, Michael.
Who do you want
to do the deal with?
I love all you guys. I mean,
you guys are all amazing.
O'Leary: You have
to make a decision.
Do you want a counter
to Blake and me?
I think we have an undecisive
entrepreneur right here.
Lori, let him think.
Don't worry about it.
It's only the most
important decision of your life.
I appreciate all the offers
and all the interest
and all the feedback.
It means the world to me
for how much effort
I've put into this.
It's very validating,
so thank you.
Just thank you.
It's been a really crazy year.
And...?
Um...
The equity side
is a bit too much
that I'm willing to give up.
Ooh.
So I don't know
if there's a way to ‐‐
What would we do?
And then, Mark, I mean,
I'd love to work
with you also, obviously.
Is there any way you
come down a little bit
just to meet me somewhere?
And I have to negotiate
a little bit.
15%. Would that work?
And we can get this done
and start going.
18, you got a deal.
No. I'll do it for 15.
18, you got ‐‐
I'll do it for 15.
O'Leary: Yes or no to 18?
You just made me an offer.
Are you gonna live up to it?
I'll do it for 15.
Mark, you got a deal.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Unh! Unh!
I love you guys.
Mark jerked that
from both of you!
Yes!
Mycoskie:
How did that just happen?!
Thank you!
No!
We're hugging next year.
I'm telling you.
Thank you so much.
No!
I love both of you very much.
Look at me!
John: I thought you
were gonna blow that!
Look at me! Look at me!
Congratulations, man.
O'Leary: Michael, Michael,
Michael ‐‐
Look at me.
You can change your mind.
Mycoskie: What just happened?
I thought we had a deal!
Pan: Thank you very much.
I loved it.
I appreciate it.
Let's go!
We're gonna crush it!
Let's go! Thank you.
♪♪
Were you in with Blake
and then you snaked him
and went in by yourself
and said 15?
Yes! Yes! Yes!
Greiner: I‐I‐I ‐‐
[ Laughing ] I was doing
whatever it takes.
And then Mark
snaked you both?
[ Laughs ]
You just got shitaake'd!
That's it.
We did!
Pan: I've been on this path
for a while,
and being the sole entrepreneur
for so long,
[Voice breaking] you go through
so many peaks and valleys,
and...
and this year especially,
seeing your bank account
go negative,
seeing people's lives at risk...
This is the biggest
one of them all,
and just to have this happen...
is extremely
emotionally satisfying.
[ Chuckling ] Sorry.
♪♪
I invested in Mo's Bows
and Me & The Bees
when they were just young kids.
Now they've grown up,
and I am so proud to see
what they've accomplished.
I strongly suggest
that you don't take on investors
at this time.
I think that mentoring
is more valuable.
When I pitched on "Shark Tank,"
I was just 11 years old.
I'm now 18 years old.
Mo's Bows has now done
$750,000 in sales.
I appeared
as a fashion correspondent
for the ESPN NBA draft.
I even got invited
to the White House,
where I met
President Barack Obama
and gave him his own bow tie.
That was one of the greatest
moments of my life.
I decided to create a product
that helps save the bees
and uses my great‐granny Helen's
recipe, as well.
Alright.
Ulmer: I pitched my business
when I was just 9 years old.
It's kind of unbelievable to me
that as a 16‐year‐old,
my product has now grown
to have over 1,500
points of distribution
in over 40 states.
My business has now done
well over $3 million in sales.
I want to become
a serial social entrepreneur
and maybe even a Shark one day,
like Mr. Daymond.
Make sure you tell
your wonderful families
that I said hello.
I love seeing you guys, and I
love seeing your progress,
and I can't wait to
see you in person when
this whole thing is over
and be able to give you
a big ol' hug.
Thanks, Daymond.
I love you.
John: Mo and Mikaila
are a true inspiration.
I've watched them grow.
I watched them grow
their businesses.
More importantly,
I've watched them
and their family
challenge themselves
and now inspire other people.
And I couldn't be
more proud of them.
Bridges: For kids who
want to be entrepreneurs,
my advice is to figure out
what you like doing,
find out how you can help
other people by doing it.
Also, find out how
you can make money
by doing that passion, as well.
Ulmer: If you're a kid
and you're looking
to start a company,
look around for things that
could be fixed or improved,
and don't be afraid
to ask questions.
John: A lot of people want
to create change right now,
and the easiest way to do that
is to mentor somebody.
I have so much hope for our next
generation of entrepreneurs.
They are out here
to change the planet
and reach for the stars,
to educate people
and keep inspiring people,
and they are inspiring me,
as well.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a way
to protect your loved ones
from dangers in the air.
♪♪
Oh!
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Kirby Holmes.
I'm from Austin, Texas.
This is my cousin.
Hey, Sharks.
My name's Evan Daugherty,
also from Austin, Texas.
And we're here seeking $200,000
for 20% of our company.
We live in a time
when people are questioning
the quality of the air
they breathe,
with an increase
in smoke from wildfires,
dust storms,
and ‐‐ oh, yeah ‐‐
the coronavirus.
And while we've all gotten
more comfortable
wearing a filter mask
to protect ourselves
from air pollution
and other threats,
what about the ones
we really love?
Dogs...
[ Laughter ]
are like members
of our family.
Mycoskie: You're kidding me.
[ Laughter ]
My dogs would kill me
if I put this on them.
And that is why we created
the world's first
air filter mask for dogs,
called the K9 Mask.
Now pet owners have
a safe and effective way
to protect their pets
from air pollution
and other threats.
It's specifically designed to
fit the shape of a dog's muzzle.
Our N95
and activated carbon air filters
are replaceable,
so you can wash the mask,
because we know dogs ‐‐
they make a super
slobbery mess.
That's right.
The canine mask also comes
in four different sizes
to fit various
muzzle shapes.
It features two
adjustable straps...
[ Laughter ]
...one around the neck
and one around the chin
to provide
a secure fit
but still allowing your dog
room to pant ‐‐
something we can all
wag our tails at.
Sharks, who's ready
to help all dogs breathe better
with a K9 Mask?
Why?
So, it's a carbon filter?
Holmes: It's an N95...
An N95?
and activated carbon
air filter.
How did you come up
with this idea?
So, here's the story.
Five years ago,
I'm on a date with my wife.
We're at a nice cafe.
I go into the bathroom,
and I'm washing my hands.
Young guy walks in,
looks really sharp.
Now, the problem
with that guy is,
he was wearing
a blue surgical mask.
When was this?
This is in 2015.
Okay.
And I thought, if this guy's
trying to impress his date,
it's not gonna work.
I thought, you know,
the problem with this guy is,
he needed
an air filter mask
that would accessorize
with his clothing.
Well, I decided to
start an affiliate website
with stylish and fashionable
air filter face masks.
Then in 2017,
when we saw that
the California wildfires
were beginning to increase
in volume and intensity...
There you go.
And so when I saw
on my website
somebody used the search term
"air filter mask for dogs,"
boom, it hit me.
That's a great idea.
If people are struggling
with air quality,
like wildfire smoke ‐‐
People love their pets.
Okay. I get it
in a wildfire,
So, really,
it was for fires.
but think about the problem
you're gonna have with dogs.
Dogs, they stake out
their territory with urine.
And it's very important
when you're walking your dog
that they check out
who's in town.
Sure.
And so they have to be ‐‐
Cuban: Yeah, but, Kevin,
that's irrelevant.
It's absolutely irrelevant.
Look, if you're by
the wildfires in California
and you're trying
to protect your pet
and you haven't
been evacuated...
Holmes: Right.
...what are
you gonna do?
Right? 'Cause your pet is ‐‐
This is not a leisure product.
Holmes: You're talking
about a casual situation
where your dog's
on a walk.
We're talking about
a crisis situation.
So, this is crisis masks?
Yes.
Now, that's why
we created the product,
but listen ‐‐
here's the other things
that are happening
around the world.
When there is a red tide,
toxic algae bloom
that's around Florida...
Right.
...that is a toxin
that you don't want to breathe,
and you don't want
your dog to breathe.
Correct.
O'Leary: So, Kirby,
I give you $200,000.
How do I find these
special‐situation dog owners?
'Cause I can't sell to the dogs.
They don't have credit cards.
You go anywhere
that's had a wildfire.
Why don't we ask them
about their sales?
'Cause then they're gonna either
prove us right or wrong.
Cuban: Exactly.
Yeah. What are your sales?
So, $204,000 in
the last 14 months.
Ooh.
♪ Wah‐wah‐wah‐wah‐wah ♪
Greiner: And that
includes COVID.
So, people worried
about this during COVID.
Did you get a spike?
Yes.
Now, we did $45,000 in sales
last year.
We had $159,000 in sales
this year.
I love that you
created this,
that you're caring
about dogs.
I mean, you should
have them for cats, too.
[ Both chuckle ]
Yeah,
try putting one on a cat.
Well, why stop there?
What about raccoons?
What about rats?
[ Laughter ]
What about mice?
They need masks.
We have thought about the design
for cats, for horses.
Mycoskie: We haven't got
into the pricing. Sorry.
How much are you
retailing it for?
How much does it cost?
Retails for $59.
And how much does it
cost landed to make?
Costs us $25.
They're made here?
Oh, you're made here?
So, don't you, you know ‐‐
Another alternative's
you just get a new dog.
[ Laughter ]
Like, that is expensive.
Oh, God.
Who is this guy?
I think it's a brilliant idea.
I think it's a great execution.
The real problem I'm having,
the sales aren't enough, right?
You got to explain
to me why sales
aren't dramatically higher.
It would be great if more people
knew about our brand.
We need to get awareness
around this product.
Mycoskie: I love the part
of your story about, you know,
kind of seeing
what people are searching for.
But now more than ever,
people are searching for masks,
and I assume
they're searching ‐‐
some ‐‐
for masks for dogs,
but that's not translating
into sales.
And so that's where I have
the biggest problem with this.
No one's buying.
♪♪
Well, it's up
to you to decide.
Is no one buying when
you sell 200,000 of something ‐‐
$200,000 worth
of something?
People are buying.
Well, they're buying,
but I think what Blake is saying
is that it's just not buying
in the type of magnitude
that you might expect.
For me,
this is just too niche.
So, I wish you good luck.
Understand.
But I'm out.
Thank you, Lori.
Daugherty: Thank you, Lori.
The one thing we really need
from somebody here
is to say, "Hey, let's lower
the cost of your manufacturing."
It's a good product,
like I said earlier.
The real problem I'm having,
the sales aren't enough.
So for those reasons, I'm out.
Okay. Thanks, Mark.
Thanks, Mark.
I love where
your heart's at.
Like, I have four dogs myself,
and I would do anything
to protect them
in a challenging situation.
Absolutely.
But, like Lori said,
I just don't think
that you proved that there's
a big enough market of people
who are gonna pull the trigger
and spend $59 for this.
So for that reason,
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Thanks, Blake. Yeah.
Thanks, Blake.
No. I'm out.
♪♪
I think maybe what
some of you are missing, though,
are people feel like their pet
is a part of their family.
And if a member
of your family
John:
I think we understand that,
is in crisis and hurting
and there's potential harm ‐‐
but everybody's saying
the same thing.
Like, $200,000 worth of sales,
it's not horrible.
I mean, it's proof of concept.
It shows that there's a need.
But I'm gonna make you
an offer.
Cuban: Oh!
So, the deal is $200,000
for 45%.
O'Leary: Ouch.
Mm.
♪♪
Daymond, do you have
any flexibility on your equity?
Yeah.
55% for $200,000.
Okay.
Now you know where you stand,
but at least you have an offer.
Holmes: Right. Daymond,
I appreciate the offer.
What do you want to do?
Would you be willing
to go down to 30%
No.
to be a part of this
with us?
No, I'm only giving you ‐‐
I'm only asking 45
so that you guys own
majority of the company.
I would normally ask 50%.
'Cause this is ‐‐ I'm literally
50% gonna throw away my money.
[ Whispering ]
Would you do a deal
at 40% with us?
♪♪
Alright.
You got a deal.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: There you go!
Thank you, Daymond!
Woof! Woof! Woof! Woof!
[ Laughter ]
We're gonna help
a lot of dogs.
This dawg right here,
alright?
Nice job, guys.
John: Thank you, guys.
We'll care for you.
Greiner: Congrats, guys.
Thank you so much, guys.
Appreciate it.
Cuban: Congrats.
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Yes! We did it, man!
I can't believe it.
We got a deal with these guys.
Love it!
I'm just thinking,
when I'm in the city
when I'm walking my dog,
my dog is smelling everything,
and I really just thought
about it ‐‐ holy crap.
That snout has been coming in
after smelling a bunch of ‐‐
Greiner: Yeah, it's kinda gross.
Daymond, can you imagine
the first time you try
to put that
on a German Shepherd?
Mycoskie: No way
that my dog ‐‐
That German Shepherd
looks really pissed off.
[ Laughing ]
They all look pissed.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an easier way
to achieve peace
and tranquility.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Aisha.
And I'm Faheem,
and we're seeking
$200,000
in exchange
for 10% of our business,
Moment.
Have you ever had
one of those stressful
afternoons in the office,
the ones that are filled
with endless meetings,
deadlines, and to‐dos?
I know I have!
[ Laughter ]
And what makes it
even worse
is that every time
you're looking for some relief,
everything you're surrounded by
is either sugary or caffeinated.
It would give me
the jitters!
Well, that used to be the case,
until this Moment!
Moment is a natural
botanical beverage
that reduces stress
and feels like meditation!
[ Laughter ]
Moment uses
a proprietary formulation
that stimulates
the same alpha brain waves
as does meditation.
We use three primary
active ingredients
to make that happen ‐‐
L‐theanine and natural extract
of green tea.
♪ For focus ♪
Number two is ashwagandha,
an ancient Ayurvedic root.
♪ For calmness ♪
And number three is tulsi,
our holy basil,
an adaptogenic verb.
♪ For stress relief ♪
[ Laughter ]
Moment is the first product
in the world
that lets you drink
your meditation.
And what makes it
even better
is that each Moment has less
than 15 calories,
no sugar, no caffeine,
nothing artificial.
And ‐‐ Oh, my goodness!
Each one
is absolutely delicious!
Sharks, stress is
a major problem ‐‐
today more than ever.
And this is the Moment
to solve it.
[ Applause ]
Mycoskie: Man. I mean,
what a performance.
O'Leary: Yeah.
So, Sharks, now it's time
for you to take a Moment
for yourself.
We've got all three
of our flavors
for you to sample.
On your left,
you've got Tulsi Lemon,
a drink I grew up
having in Pakistan.
You've got Rooibos Blood Orange,
inspired by South Africa,
which is
where Faheem is from.
O'Leary: Is there any
artificial sweetener in here?
There's no
artificial sweetener.
No artificial ‐‐
Nothing artificial at all.
This is pretty damn good.
This is good.
Chottani: Love it!
Great.
That's great to hear.
I love the space
of dealing
with the chronic stress
in our country.
Yeah.
A company that
I'm a co‐founder of right now,
Madefor,
that's our entire mission.
I meditate every day.
It's had a huge impact
on my life.
Not to be cynical, but I don't
understand how a drink is gonna
give me the same feeling
of this practice
that I've curated
over years and years.
Absolutely.
We found that meditation
helped us be a lot more focused,
a lot more creative.
But all our friends
find it very difficult
to actually get into.
And one of the key reasons
that we started this was
to help people get
an entry point into meditation.
We're trying to create a habit
in a person's daily life,
and every time somebody
actually subscribes for Moment,
a portion of our proceeds
actually goes to
helping kids in school
learn about mindfulness.
Great.
Tell us about you.
Yeah, where'd you go
to drama school?
[ Both laugh ]
So, I have been working
in supply chain and logistics
for the last 10 years.
I grew up in Pakistan,
where my dad was
a small entrepreneur.
I was fortunate enough
to get into
Harvard Business School,
which is how I ended up
moving here.
Um...
My dad would've been so proud
to see me here today,
had he been alive.
I, um...
You know, honestly, it's been
a very difficult journey.
My dad was amazing.
I remember when
I got into college,
there was people
calling him
and telling him that he should
not send me to college
because that's not
the right decision,
given I was a girl,
but my parents,
they stood up against everyone.
And not only that,
when I graduated from college,
I wanted to pursue
a professional life.
My parents pushed back
against everyone
to make sure I didn't get into
an arranged marriage situation.
I wanted to go
explore the world,
and my parents supported me
through that.
And that's how I ended up going
to South Africa.
Like, I found a job there,
I moved there,
and that's
when I met Faheem.
Faheem:
So, I'm from South Africa.
I have always
been involved
in this kind
of entrepreneurial space.
My last startup
was fortunate enough
to be funded by Google
and was chosen
as the best startup
in South Africa at the time.
What was it?
It was
a consumer tech startup
that helped people share
and discover shopping deals.
Love the backstory.
Now tell the front story.
Now we're gonna talk
about Moment.
Awesome.
What is the game plan
for world domination?
Honestly, we got into
the beverage industry ‐‐
we realized that we were
cockroaches in the industry
because of all
these behemoths...
That's important.
...and because of the margin
structure and distribution.
We totally understand.
That's why we chose
an online‐first
distribution model.
So, we just launched
a month and a half back,
and we've already done
$15,000 in sales.
We've grown 400%
and are on track to do
$1.5 million of sales this year.
And what's the price for each
one, and what's it cost you?
Yeah, so, we sell it for $1.69,
excluding shipping.
It costs us 90 cents
to make it right now.
Shipping per can
is about 80 cents.
Do you know what your customer
acquisition cost is yet?
It's a little bit
over $20.
$20 customer acquisition cost
on how much of an initial order?
Between an $18 and a $30.
So you're losing money
on the first order.
That's totally right.
Yeah.
But we are really driving
towards a subscription model,
which drives us towards
our longer‐term value.
And, honestly,
our purpose is to really
understand the customer
and build that relationship.
Guys, I mean, I see what
you're trying to accomplish.
It's, "Let's get people who are
into this lifestyle excited."
You're selling
on the improvement
that you find in your life.
That's
your value proposition.
You know, that's where
the real value comes,
and this just happens
to be the delivery mechanism
that you've chosen.
The question becomes,
is this the right vehicle?
And at $30 every two weeks,
or $15,
that's gonna be
a challenge for me.
And so for those reasons,
I'm out.
The beverage industry
is probably the most
difficult industry on Earth
to gain share in.
Om!
Let's talk with that
for a moment.
We embrace the fact
that it's hard.
Yeah.
But wait. It gets better.
Never in the history
of beverage,
from the time
of Genghis Khan,
has anybody got
a subscription model to work.
Ever! Never!
Not once.
But wait ‐‐ you're gonna
try and do that.
So,
"om" on the first problem,
breaking into
an impossible sector.
And secondly, doing something
that's never been done before.
And you want a valuation
of $2 million
on something
you've just started.
Wait, wait, wait.
Now we go
to Greek mythology.
Greiner: Oh, no. Don't.
Oh, no!
We don't have
enough time for this!
Because Atlas was cursed...
We do not have enough time.
...to carry the Earth
on his back.
That's what you're doing.
I really like you guys.
We really like you, as well.
But you couldn't have
come into the Tank
with more weight on you
than this.
I'm out.
Listen, first off,
I just have to say,
you not only
do your father proud,
but you do
all women proud.
Thank you.
Your packaging
is beautiful.
I love it.
It draws you right to it.
But for me,
I feel that this concept,
the subscription concept
part of it,
I'm not sure about,
because I'm not sure that people
want to have delivered
their drinks.
For that reason,
I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
Thank you.
We appreciate those kind words.
I do agree that you can get
subscription models,
but in a different way.
I think if you had
a concentrated form ‐‐
I have a subscription model
for turmeric
and a lot
of other vitamins,
which I think
that you could concentrate this
and put it in a little bottle
and squeeze it into water.
But I'm not here
to change your business model.
I see there's potentially
a lot of challenges.
So with that, I'm out.
Thank you.
Thanks for the feedback.
Okay, it's me.
Whoo‐hoo!
I think that Moment
is an amazing name.
I love that you're taking
a portion of the proceeds
of your company
and giving them back
to helping children
learn to meditate.
I'm also a huge believer
in science
and using science to help
address the chronic stress
that millions of Americans
experience every day.
The problem here is,
I would be a hypocrite
if I said that
I think a drink can do
what everything else
I think in my life has shown me,
and that is,
you got to do the work,
and you got to do the habits
so you can get to a place
where you can address
these stresses of modern living.
So because of that...
I'm out.
♪♪
Cuban: Sorry, guys.
Okay.
Thank you very much for all
your feedback.
Thank you so much.
Cuban: Appreciate it, guys.
Good luck, you guys.
Congratulations
on what you accomplished.
Thank you.
Kajee: We started
this business
because we wanted to have
a real impact on people's lives,
and we're still as excited
as ever about doing that.
So from here on,
it's getting Moment out
to the rest of America.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is
a cleaner, eco‐friendly way
to cook outdoors.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Riki Franco.
And I'm Oron Franco,
and we're from New York City.
We're here asking for $200,000
for 10% equity in our company.
Sharks, summertime means
soaking up the great outdoors
and grilling up
a mouthwatering masterpiece.
But let's face it ‐‐ grilling
with traditional charcoal
we've all been
accustomed to
has become more work
than it's worth.
From lugging bags
of heavy coals,
constantly
babysitting the fire,
and cleaning up
all this messy ash ‐‐
[ Groans ]
Yikes.
It leaves you with no time
to enjoy your food
and your company.
So, Sharks, we reinvented
this outdated experience
and elevated it
to a whole new level.
We created...
Both: Prime 6!
Our charcoal is
100% sustainable, all‐natural,
made solely from
repurposed sawdust.
Our hexagon shape
allows heat
to evenly distribute
throughout the grill,
burning longer and hotter
than any other.
And the best part ‐‐
it's completely reusable.
That's right.
When you're done grilling,
simply turn it off,
close the lid to choke the
oxygen, and let the fire rest.
And when you're ready to
get back to grilling again,
you can simply
relight it.
And when it finally does burn
all the way out,
there is no cleanup.
Prime 6 is
self‐consuming,
leaving your grill
with low to no ash.
Our product is all‐natural
and chemical‐free,
made with absolutely
no nasty fuels or additives,
to help save trees
while keeping you
and Mother Nature healthy
in the process.
So, tell us ‐‐
who's burning
to light up a deal with us?
Whoo!
[ Chuckles ] Good job.
Wow.
Cuban: Good job, guys.
Can you tell us
what it's made out of?
It's not compressed coal?
It's not compressed coal.
It's actually
compressed sawdust.
We use only hardwood,
and we compress
the sawdust first,
and then we carbonize it
to create the product.
And what does it cost
versus ordinary charcoal?
We're paying less than half
on any average charcoal
because our briquettes
saves you three times
the amount of charcoal
you would ‐‐
So, the value proposition is,
I don't have to clean up a mess,
I'm paying half as much,
I'm burning hotter.
Price point ‐‐ for the same‐size
log, it's the same price?
Yes.
So, one of these
versus the log that I might ‐‐
a 9‐pound log that I might see
at a Home Depot?
Riki:
Let me answer that.
This 9‐pound actually cost
$18.99, retail price,
but it is actually equal
to 30 pounds of charcoal.
O'Leary: You sell this
for $18.99 retail,
and what's it cost you
to make it?
$3.39.
That's not bad.
We currently sell
the 22‐pound to Wal‐Mart
for $26.64,
and we sell the 9‐pound for
anywhere from $10.99 to $12.99.
How did you come up
with this idea?
We saw a similar‐looking product
in Vietnam years ago.
So, had that
stuck with you for years?
Like, you constantly talk about
"Remember that charcoal?"
We always talked about it.
We always talked about that.
And, you know, back home,
we used to grill all the time.
Like, this is something
that's part of the family ‐‐
O'Leary: But the Vietnam story
tells me something else.
There's nothing proprietary
about this, right?
We haven't gotten
to that part yet.
One second.
You're jumping the gun.
Well, chop‐chop.
We said, "Listen,
we want to be making this ‐‐
We want to be taking
this process
and making it
100% sustainable."
What we do, we take the sawdust
when it's still raw,
we compress it under, you know,
a few tons of pressure
While it's wet?
No. You heat it up a little bit.
You get it warm.
The natural oils
from that sawdust
are enough
to bind it back to wood ‐‐
denser than any wood
you would find in nature ‐‐
and carbonize it
like lump charcoal.
Do you have a patent?
We have applied
for a provisional patent,
we have applied
for a design patent,
and we have
a patent pending
on the hexagon packaging,
as well.
So, how long will
this burn for?
This will burn
four to eight hours.
Really?
Depending on the size
of the...
Without replenishing.
Sales?
Yes.
So, we launched
12 months ago.
We are currently
over $300,000 in sales,
and we're selling
food service, retail,
both in stores
and e‐commerce.
And how are you selling?
Are you advertising
or are you going door to door?
Distributors are
most of your sales?
Let me tell you
the story.
So, we basically
loaded the back of our cars,
and I went out driving
every day to restaurants,
to stores,
basically...
Hustle, hustle, hustle.
...selling the product.
I like it.
Mycoskie: Wow.
And then, also, I noticed
you've said the word
"sustainable" several times,
and it's at the very top
of your packaging here.
So what is your mission
with the company?
I don't think you can do
anything, really,
without doing some good,
as well.
I agree.
So the fact
that it's natural
and it's made from sawdust
is actually cleaning waste.
There's another element
to the company.
That is, you buy one,
we plant one.
Mm.
So we've partnered up
with this amazing organization
called One Tree Planted.
Cool.
And for every pack,
whether it's the 9‐pound
or the 22‐pound,
we plant a tree.
And what does that
cost you to do that?
$1 per tree.
$1.
You valued this business
at 2 million bucks ‐‐
$200,000 for 10%, right?
Yeah.
You're not making any money yet
after you pay yourselves?
That's not true, actually.
We don't pay ourselves,
and we are profitable.
Wait.
You don't pay yourselves?
No.
But we will pay for ourselves
starting next week.
You will what?
Uh‐oh!
Oh! You're pulling out
a purchase order.
What you got?
This is a $130,000,
six‐figure PO from Lowes
that arrived yesterday,
and this is our first launch.
Greiner: Good for you.
Good for you.
Going next week,
making us a $450,000 company.
Okay. That's attractive.
But that's the beginning
of the journey.
You want to make this thing big,
you're gonna accept this offer.
You ready for it?
Yeah.
There's a reason
they call me Mr. Wonderful.
You know that.
We know that.
I'll give you the $200,000
for 25%.
Mm.
25%, and I'll tell you why.
This is gonna take work.
You got to open up doors.
I'd rather sell it direct,
frankly.
Yeah.
We did 65% direct.
Yeah,
I'd rather blow that up
because right now,
retail's chaos.
You learned yourself
how hard it is.
Yeah.
But that's the deal. It would
make me get up in the morning...
That's actually one
of the better offers
Kevin's ever made.
John: It is.
It actually is.
Thank you, Mr. Wonderful.
Greiner: So, Mark and I
did a deal a few years back
with a product
called InstaFire.
Are you familiar with it?
Yeah.
InstaFire, you know,
was a fire starter.
And it's not a charcoal
briquette like this.
But my problem here is
that Mark and I
do have InstaFire
and...
Is it a conflict
of interest?
I'm concerned about that...
Yeah.
...because I don't
want to do a deal
with a company
where you're competing
with the company
we already have.
Because I'm not sure,
I, regrettably, am out.
What you've been able
to accomplish is great,
but it's just not a product
that I can get excited about,
particularly with InstaFire,
you know,
'cause I think it would
create some conflicts for me
in working with them.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
I appreciate it.
Thank you, Mark.
Alright, well, you got
an offer on the table ‐‐
you know, Kevin.
O'Leary: Yeah, I mean...
You want to do anything?
[ Sighs ] You want
to do it together or...?
I don't know.
No, no. Don't need
any help on this one.
While you guys think about it,
I just want to say,
I have to be super, super
passionate about it,
and I just don't feel
that personal passion
that you guys have.
And so for that reason,
I'm going to be out.
Okay.
Thank you, Blake.
Let me tell you one thing,
Daymond, before you ‐‐
O'Leary: Wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let's remember that
Mr. Wonderful made you an offer.
If Daymond drops out,
bad things could happen,
because then I have
ultimate leverage.
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Riki and Oron have an offer
on the table from Kevin
for their innovative
charcoal company, Prime 6,
but they have yet
to hear from Daymond.
Think about the jeopardy.
Now, I'm Mr. Wonderful
for a reason ‐‐
'cause I'm wonderful.
But if I know
Daymond's out...
I may squeeze a little bit.
Greiner:
But Daymond isn't out.
Okay, Mr. Wonderful.
Why don't you starting thinking
about the only offer you have?
Let me counter.
Would you do it for 20%?
No.
Cuban: Oh, Kevin!
Okay.
And I'll tell you why.
'Cause you don't trust your
own skills to grow the company.
I'm in this space.
It is tough. It is hard.
It's not gonna be easy
to sell restaurants
for another year and a half.
I want to go
direct to customer.
I have the channels
to do that.
And I'm also Chef Wonderful.
We are not selling retail.
You know why?
There is no retail
right now.
It's very, very hard
to get paid.
And you're giving up 35% margin.
That's the problem.
I'd rather capture that margin
for us so I can wet my beak.
You understand.
I do. Okay.
Mycoskie: There's a lot
of good logic right there.
I mean,
I'm out of the deal,
but if I'm an entrepreneur
right now and I just heard that,
I think I might
take this deal.
Kevin makes
a lot of sense.
Of course he does.
He's Mr. Wonderful.
Daymond, if you don't mind,
I would love to hear...
Listen,
I am a professional griller.
Cuban: Yes, we know.
Really?
Daymond: I am.
But you are not a chef.
I'm a professional griller.
That's interesting.
I came from a neighborhood
where simple and plain,
the person
behind the grill
is the closest you'll ever get
to royalty.
That's it. Alright?
So, I'm gonna match
Kevin's offer ‐‐
$200,000 for 25%.
Ooh, decisions,
decisions.
Well, then. Remember ‐‐
It it just
"Who do you like more?"
♪♪
Can you give us
a few seconds?
[ Whispers ]
Okay. Okay.
That's what you do.
Kevin, you have a deal.
John: You like Kevin more?!
Cuban:
Oh, Daymond! Daymond!
Mycoskie: Wow!
Oh, my God!
Thank God I realized
they were not bright.
I'm gonna sell
the [bleep] out of this.
Congratulations, guys.
Well done.
Greiner: Congrats, guys.
O'Leary: Take care.
[ Both chuckle ]
[ Laughing ]
Oh, my God!
What just happened?!
What just happened?
This is so surreal!
This is insane.
This is surreal!
[ Voice breaking ]
We sold from the back
of our car a year ago.
I mean, literally from
the back of the car.
And to think that
a year from now,
we will be, you know,
so far ahead,
millions of dollars in sales
and having Kevin on the team,
it's just...
[ Sighs ]
It's phenomenal.
To "Shark Tank"!
This is the American dream
for us.
Yeah.
♪♪